[Music]  right now fill it of the day here it's a  guy named Bill Maher here's what he said  about well billionaire David Koch who  passed away yesterday David Koch of the  zillionaire Koch brothers died plays of  prostate cancer I guess I'm going to  have to reevaluate my low opinion of  prostate cancer so him the Amazon is  burning up I'm glad he's dead  I hold a message for Bill you know I  never called for his firing its  conservatives who stood up from when he  worked at ABC not liberals I never call  for boycotts I'm not gonna start out  you're a jackass you're a mean-spirited  jackass I have other words I really want  to use but unlike you I work at a  network that has some standards and if I  said it I have to spend all day tomorrow  and the next day dealing with that crap  the guy you're talking about and his  wife donated 1.3 billion dollars to  charity until you do that just keep your  big mouth shut